Alice thank you so much for joining me
today I want to ask you a little bit
about your chess upbringing there's been
a lot talked about you in the media but
I want to hear it again from you I
started playing chess when I was 6 years
old um so my brother was going to the
school chess club and uh I went to lawn
also because my parents just wanted to
drop us up at the same time um so after
I started playing in the chess club I
was actually like one of the very worst
and uh for me it was just I lost a lot I
was kind of upset but as I kept uh
actually not losing every single game I
became more motivated and eventually I
played in my first rated tournament uh
that summer and from there I think it
was just I really loved the game which
allowed me to continue to enjoy chess
while playing it very nice and how did
you get into playing a lot online and
how do you combine that with um studying
over the board yeah um so I think
especially in the recent years there's
been a lot of uh new chess resources
both online and also books published um
so for me I did go over some uh books
for example the 100 end games you must
know um and Mauricio flor's uh Pawn
structures book um I also used like uh
some online tools for example chess
Tempo and chess AO um I think they have
a lot of great resources and for me uh I
think especially in this new generation
uh where everything is just so much
stronger it's really great to have all
these new resources and you're spending
a lot of time online could you give me
an approximate U amount of time that you
spend per day working on chess um so
actually this year I'm doing online
school so it makes it flexible for my
schedule um so I guess before high
school started I was spending like a
couple hours a day on chess sometimes
more especially during the summer when I
was playing in a lot of tournaments uh
now the high school is started uh it's
more work um so I have to I guess find a
new balance since for me it's my first
first year and I haven't really had to
do something like this in the past um
but I hope that at least I'll be able to
find some sort of balance between school
work and chess and I'll be able to at
least play well in this tournament
you've had some amazing results lately
congratulations for winning gold medal
uh at the women's world team
championship how was that how did you
feel that moment yeah so that was
actually like the first tournament that
I played in uh like internationally on
that stage so I think it was really
great for me to be able to do so well
there and of course it was like a really
great experience to be playing on the
first board against such strong players
um I I definitely wasn't expecting to uh
win the gold medow there I was just
hoping you know I could at least do okay
um but uh for me it was great that uh I
was able to have like really good
results and it was my first like really
really strong it was a really great
experience for me do you feel nervous at
all or did you feel at that time nervous
because you're you know representing the
United States and it was your first
competition of this kind yeah I mean uh
so beforehand I actually thought I was
playing on the second board so I was
like okay not as much pressure and then
when I went there I was like oh I'm
playing on board one okay um so it is a
team event and there's something nice
which is that um even if you don't have
your desired result uh you can still
hope that your teammates also do well um
of course there's a little bit more
pressure as well because you want to win
for your team um but for me I was just
like trying to focus game at the game
and I was able to like find I guess uh a
good start and then after that I think I
just got a some good results very very
awesome congratulations again for that I
want to ask you one more thing regarding
this tournament um so last year as you
mentioned maybe your result wasn't as
great but you've had a great U year
where you've improved a lot um I think
you were supposed to get your
International Master title very soon and
this year you're one of the favorites do
you feel any pressure at all or have you
been able by now to deal with all your
emotions and are you just going to take
it a day a game at yeah uh so so last
year I was I think a lot more
inexperienced and this year I've played
in like a lot more strong tournaments so
I have slightly more experience I mean
uh for me I guess I am one of the top
Seas but I don't think I'm like the very
favorite so that's something that's kind
of nice because I don't have so much
like pressure that everybody expects me
to win um and I guess for this
tournament well I think winning would be
nice I it's also extremely hard because
the field is so strong um and for me
I'll just take it one game at a time and
try to play my best very nice thank you
so much Alice I wish you good luck and
looking forward to your
[Music]
games